[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y los
acompaño desde casa a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 iniciamos este
espacio en brásil puntualmente en la
ciudad de serrana donde se lleva a cabo
un estudio epidemiológico único en el
mundo para determinar la eficacia de la
vacuna china coronaba que a la hora de
prevenir los contagios del virus
el objetivo fue inocular casi a la
totalidad de la población de la ciudad
un lugar con una alta tasa de contagio
significa que significa mucho fue muy
bueno que haya ocurrido porque vamos a
quedar inmunizados nos vamos a librar de
esta enfermedad
somos privilegiados somos privilegiados
y agradecemos mucho este proyecto que
nos está ayudando en este momento en
este momento según los datos oficiales
más del 97% de los residentes de la
ciudad fueron inmunizados y serán
monitoreados durante un año el
porcentaje restante corresponde a
menores de 18 años mujeres embarazadas o
lactantes y personas que registraron
cuadros de fiebre 72 horas antes
y la inyección el estudio ha sido
realizado con la supervisión del centro
de investigación butantán y también
servirá para medir el impacto que la
inmunización a gran escala pueda tener
tanto en el sistema de salud como en la
economía y la circulación de personas al
tiempo permitirá conocer reacciones
adversas a la vacunación y la
interacción de la vacuna con la variante
brasileña conocida como p 1
serra no fue subdividida en 25 pequeñas
áreas estamos analizando la cobertura
inmunológica de cada una de estas áreas
para determinar si esto tiene relación
con la inmunidad de rebaño y con la
reducción de casos graves y
hospitalizaciones
como la respuesta inmunológica total de
coronaba que sólo se ve dos semanas
después de haberse aplicado en la
segunda dosis a todo el público objetivo
las primeras conclusiones del
experimento sólo podrán conocerse hacia
mediados de mayo
la situación en brasil que continúa
siendo el epicentro global de la
pandemia sigue siendo crítica y ahora
hay un fenómeno que inquieta a los
investigadores por primera vez desde el
inicio del brote los menores de 40 años
son los principales ocupantes de las
unidades de cuidado intensivo así lo
revela el más reciente reporte de la
asociación brasileña de medicina
intensiva que puntualiza que durante el
último mes más del 52% de las camas de
terapia intensiva las ocuparon personas
de 40 años o menos
en la primera ola vimos principalmente a
personas mayores pero eso no es lo que
estamos viendo ahora
y estos jóvenes están posponiendo ir al
hospital porque están más relajados con
la enfermedad porque esos jóvenes
por ello llegan en una condición mucho
más grave no veo a las autoridades no
conocen puntualmente las causas de esta
variación sin embargo indican que la
variante p1 podría estar relacionada con
la sintomatología grave en personas
jóvenes asimismo que la mayoría de
menores de 60 y 70 años aún no han
podido acceder a vacunas que han probado
que son altamente eficaces para evitar
que los pacientes desarrollen síntomas
graves
de brasil pasamos a mexico porque este
es el segundo país de américa latina que
anuncia el desarrollo de una vacuna
propia después de cuba la candidata se
llama patria y ya iniciaron los ensayos
clínicos si todo sale según lo planeado
el fármaco estaría listo a finales de
está en la fase de reclutamiento los
lotes vacunales para este ensayo ya
están producidos por lo menos los que
son suficientes para este primer ensayo
clínico fase 1 se reclutará 90 entre 90
y 100 voluntarios adultos
dejamos atrás del coi 19 y nos vamos a
rusia porque se conmemoraron los 60 años
desde que el cosmonauta yuri gagarín en
un hito histórico se convirtió en el
primer ser humano en salir de la tierra
gagarín orbitó a nuestro planeta y se
convirtió en un símbolo de los avances
científicos de la unión soviética
una sonrisa serena ante un despegue
hacia lo desconocido yuri gagarín fue
elegido entre un grupo de élite de
pilotos de guerra soviéticos en parte
por sus nervios de acero el 12 de abril
de 1961 el joven de 27 años se deslizaba
dentro de una pequeña cápsula diseñada
para transportar una cabeza nuclear
pocos garantizaban que sobreviviría los
más optimistas le daban un 50% de
posibilidades cuando lo propulsaron
hacia el cielo mantuvo un tono confiado
yo puedo ver la tierra las distintas
capas del paisaje los bosques y las
nubes
la cápsula viajo a 28 mil kilómetros por
hora en una hora y 48 minutos se
completó la órbita a la tierra una
innegable victoria para la unión
soviética que se convirtió en el primer
país en mandar un hombre al espacio
fue una ampliación para eeuu en medio de
la guerra fría la unión soviética se
presentaba como el líder científico
mundial que le tocó ser en ese momento
no sabíamos en que nos metíamos mandamos
a gente al espacio sin saber lo que
pasaría por eso hay un verdadero culto a
la personalidad de gagarín en rusia
están muy orgullosos de ese periodo la
siguiente misión de gagarín fue
diplomática un tour mundial para
celebrar su proeza
ver mi patria desde el espacio fue uno
de los momentos más increíbles de mi
vida
era el embajador perfecto para la unión
soviética de la encarnación a gritos él
mismo era la personificación de la
bandera soviética hijo de granjeros la
usó y herrero el martillo y todo lo que
hizo a partir de ahí todo lo que
aprendió como herrero el convertirse en
piloto de guerra fue gracias a la unión
soviética así que sabían que sería un
símbolo perfecto
después de lidiar con la depresión
finalmente volvió a entrenar pero murió
en 1968 en un ejercicio con sólo 34 años
llegaron ya llegamos hacia el final de
este espacio gracias por su compañía y
continúan con nosotros en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
ah